tyson fiore his uh his view he says for
the best place for women is being on
their backs or in the kitchen i'm glad
he's not my client when it's spilled
over go on what's a bad moment i mean
the famous one was derek gizora and
dillian white where he picked up the
table the press conference table and
threw it it was aimed at dillian white
they actually went on myself andy murray
turned down one and a half million
pounds to play in saudi because of human
rights concerns it does happen i suppose
there are individuals yeah but he's a
lot more money than that and maybe if
they offered andy murray more he would
have gone that was the boxing promoter
eddie hearn in this conversation you're
going to hear about why he didn't go to
court for anthony joshua and why men
still want to punch each other in the
face
[Music]
it's both the same
and very different
either way promoters are more powerful
than ever and the stakes are just as
high
hello and welcome my guest this week is
promoter entrepreneur and arguably one
of the most powerful people in boxing
eddie hearn his company matchroom sport
has been credited with taking boxing to
another level and his partnership with
anthony joshua has got him into a few
scrapes of his own luckily just verbal
welcome eddie thank you thanks for being
here and i wanted to start by asking why
do two people do you think want to still
punch each other in the face in 2022
it is bizarre isn't it and um
there's kind of no excuse for boxing
it's very difficult to explain to people
um and you know the the argument will
always come up if there is an injury in
the sport specifically which has become
a lot safer
how does this exist in this this modern
day world that we live in uh his
historic there's so many fundamentals to
boxing which we'll probably come to
about actually what the sport can teach
the younger generation um but none of it
really makes sense and and it's the most
compelling sport for me in the world the
most addictive sport because when you
explain it to people it is
two
men and now women as well going into a
20 by 20 foot ring to have a fight with
each other
in front of the world but what's going
on between those two people in your
experience because sometimes you will
have known both of them when you're
promoting do they actually want to hurt
the individual or is it about what
they're doing
i think that you know it's about winning
it's it's a sport at the end of the day
i don't think
sometimes people don't get on with the
opponent you know there's a there's
there's a lot of things yeah there's a
lot of things said backwards and
forwards but generally it's about it's
about winning the fight tactically going
in there and and you know executing a
performance that you've been working on
for weeks months sometimes years a
fighter's career reaches that moment but
again they aren't that these people
they're not always
normal people they can't be normal
actually to
to do what they do and to fight at that
level so you have to be a little bit
careful from my position you've got to
sell the fight hype the fight sometimes
it spills over i've been in the middle
of that quite a few times
but generally that sort of back and
forth that animosity that tension and
energy between two fighters is
ultimately what sells you know it's
what's going to create narrative and
interest
to the public and to fight fans when
it's spilled over go on what's a bad
moment i mean the famous one was derek
gizora and dillian white where he picked
up the table the press conference table
and threw it it was aimed at dillian
white but actually went on myself and
adam smith from sky and some great
photos of that and stuff like that but
were you scared not really i've been
around boxing since i was seven years
old a table being thrown at you
sort of you know
blocked it but that way that was a new
one but you know i've been around
because of you know my dad being a
promoter as well i've been around boxing
since i was eight years old i've been in
the middle of fights in press
conferences i've been in the middle of
fighters getting injured or crying
backstage or cheering backstage or you
know every kind of emotion that you see
in the sport and it's incredibly
addictive because it is it's such a
compelling sport and like i said earlier
it's just it's not normal are you any
good at fighting i had a couple of
amateur fights terrible are you tough
now i'm not tough i mean i was i'm a
silver spoon kid i don't know as my dad
always calls me but you know i i grew up
you know my weekends were hanging around
with nazim hamid or chris eubank or
frank bruno so i thought i could fight
but you you don't become really a
fighter when you come from my kind of
background you don't think no
very rarely will you find someone who's
coming for come from a you know a
privileged background really which i
would say i have you know my dad's
from dagenham you know east london but
he he was successful and i i was very
lucky but it's a different kind of life
you have to live as a fighter and to
come through the ranks like these young
men and women do you have to be made of
tougher stuff
and very rarely will you see someone
come from that kind of background
to go on and make it in the sport and
again that's what is compelling as well
to be part of that journey my dad always
said to me if you can get one percent of
the adrenaline that these fighters get
when they walk out to fight you're very
lucky man and i feel like sometimes i
get 80 because you know the buzz
is what we live for also the money must
be pretty good a billion dollar tv deal
to stream all of your fights how do you
explain your job apart from you know
being in the action what do you actually
do
well i guess i put it together um
i kind of like
when we started i started promoting
boxing which was probably about 12 or 13
years ago
i never went in with the attention to
kind of build
my profile to a level where i'm part of
the show as well and
i should have because that was the right
thing to do but it just emerged over the
years as we went but
i'm like the you know the the guy who
puts the circus together you know it's
my job to go out to build the fights to
create the narrative to sell the story
to get the public and fight fans
invested in the event and fights and
that's what we do at matrim and we've
gone of course from you know being a a
big uk promoter to being a global
powerhouse in boxing that streaming deal
is with the zone our tv partners and
streaming global streaming giant and
that's taking us into the us with a big
deal taking us into key markets like
italy spain australia
mexico and and we keep on expanding
around the world and
that's the plan for us is to dominate
boxing globally
with a different feel with a different
kind of professional touch to the live
event experience both in the arena and
for viewers watching um on the platform
so putting on that show getting it to
people putting the business side of it
together but as you mentioned there
about taking a meeting you know how does
for instance anthony joshua how does
that relationship start do you do you
give him a card how do you mean well
with anthony joshua it's actually quite
a funny story i'll tell you quickly i
received a letter once
from a gymnasium to say look you know
there's this really promising young
heavyweight but he's got himself in some
trouble and he has to appear in call and
we would like you to come
and talk about if this young man was as
good as we think he is
what could he achieve or what could the
you know the future hold for him
and i looked at the letter and thought
well i don't even know the kid i'm not
going to come not going to go i went
straight in the bin and then i went up
to the gb institute and i just heard
this noise and it was a heavy bag i know
the noise well just being moved around
you know on his pivot and i turned
around to robert mccracken the coach and
said who's that and he said that's
anthony joshua he's this kid's special
and i thought oh no that was the name on
the letter i wish i would have responded
he went on went into the olympics and
you almost hope they don't win the
olympics because then everybody's going
to be after his signature of course he
won gold in london 2012 and
in terms of british boxing and probably
world boxing as well we're probably the
first stop that you would go to for a
meeting so you know when you want to
meet other promoters you'd come to
matroom so we had that meet him
sometimes i've got the benefit of being
younger than the other promoters and
probably get on better with the younger
fighters but you know with anthony he
was a you know he was a dream signing
because he won gold at the london 2012
olympics he was a heavyweight he was
articulate did he forgive you for not
going to court
i told him a story yeah he was probably
i still couldn't believe they asked me
to do it but um he was he's very
intelligent anthony and asked a lot of
questions and i could see him sort of
look at me as if to say i'm not sure i
trust you guys
you know and i said to him at the
meeting i said look go and see everybody
and then take your time make your
decision whereas everybody else said
sign now
and he went away for about three or four
months i never heard from him and i
thought i shouldn't have said that and
then he came back and he said we want we
want to sign with you guys which was you
know a really big moment for our
business it is still a largely male
sport i know things are starting to
change but do you think in some ways
it's boxing represents in some ways an
outdated version of masculinity or is it
an important part of being a man i think
it's changing a lot you know i think i
think the world is changing and sport is
changing in that respect as well you
know the openness um across that that
area whether you're talking about mental
health you know that you see a lot of
fighters that struggle in that area as
you do with a lot of sportsmen and i
feel that
people are
willing to talk more about many
different um talking points boxing has
always got the sort of you know the
perception of being a tough guy at sport
the influx of women's boxing has been
huge for us and we've been the real
trailblazers with with the fighters to
to take that part of the sport forward
so i think it's changed a lot over the
years i think you know back
in the day if you want to say that
that's that word it was definitely a
sort of you know
brawn and it's stellar it's still it is
but i think it's changing you know
you're seeing fashion brands coming into
the sport you're seeing a younger
generation with social media and content
you're starting to understand the
characters more people are opening up
more people are willing to talk more
people talk about their trials
tribulations you know their struggles
the trash talk too trash talks great for
us because you know that's what still
that's what people want to see you know
sometimes i'll do it they don't want to
see somebody talking about their mental
health do they they want to see them
being pugilistic they want to see
and i wonder does that perpetuate
a stereotype of men that you're saying
we're moving away from in other parts
and there might not be anything wrong
with that i don't know if it is a
stereotype it's how a lot of men still
are and feel yeah but it's important for
us to tell stories i mean we're also you
know we are event promoters but we're
also content creators you know we run
our own production company we know we i
like to produce content i like to tell
the story of a fighter and their
struggle and their life because that's
how you create personalities and game
fans and you know we need fight fans to
see that side not just someone walking
in and put going head to head with
another guy and flexing his muscles tell
the story every individual in boxing has
a tremendous story tremendous story you
know i've got lawrence akoli the world
cruiserweight champion he was working at
mcdonald's in waterloo and one day he
was flipping burgers he was grossly
overweight and he saw anthony joshua win
gold at london 2012 and he walked out at
mcdonald's he says i'm gonna i'm gonna
take up boxing and change my life he's
world cruiserweight champion you know
there are so many inspirational stories
in boxing but there are some of the most
famous tyson fiore and you look at what
he likes to say publicly would you say
that is defined by role model manner his
view he says for the best place for
women is being on their backs or in the
kitchen
it's definitely not something we support
and uh he's a quite a unique individual
with that respect he's a big name yeah
he's a big name and not everybody is
everybody's role model of course not but
i suppose when you've got those in the
mix yeah but sure but for tyson fury
away from those comments now this is
also a guy that came back from pretty
much obesity and and mental illness
himself to a lot of people he is a role
model
should he be that that's based on the
individual's perception i think it's not
down to me to say whether you know i
look after myself and my family are they
things that i would want my children to
to look up to of course not i wouldn't
even want them to see it but the
fighters that i know katie taylor being
the best example
in terms of my daughters right there is
no one that i would like my kids to meet
more and be around than katy taylor so
is it very frustrating when there are
those characters in your world i mean he
said he would celebrate post-match in
2020. i'm not holding you to account
he's not my client but he did say
celebrate with cocaine and hookers you
know this these are the direct words i
think it's important to share with with
our viewers what i'm actually talking
about in the mix i also think that
regardless of the fact that yes you're
right he is a big name
it is in isolation um you're always
going to get them you're always going to
get the controversial characters
sometimes i think actually he says
things he doesn't actually mean but you
know that's another story he says nice
things about you sometimes
sometimes not often no no and but again
you're a bad businessman yeah well yeah
your last deal doesn't look so bad
exactly the record speaks for itself
there we go it's coming do you get
frustrated though by that does that
bother you it's all part of the game and
that's why when i look at those comments
although they shouldn't be said because
he does have a position as a role model
in society
they go over my head because i know the
man you know and they don't go over some
people oh i agree but but then again
this is the real life and we can't
expect perfection from everybody
especially from people that might not
have been bought up in that way and i
don't mean that disrespectfully for him
but you know these aren't normal
individuals sometimes they say stupid
things sometimes they do stupid things
we all do and sometimes people more so
than others so you know in that respect
you can never condone those comments but
you know again i go back to
boxing the community what it does for
people and i know you know again going
back to my kids there is no place
i'd rather than be
than in a boxing gym actually and as for
someone who's got two daughters i could
i never thought i'd say that until i
started to get involved with women's
boxing and what katie taylor what k
taylor taught me what how she's inspired
me you know i don't go down the gym and
start boxing because of katie taylor but
the values and the fundamentals that she
has in terms of discipline and drive and
winning would you like your daughters to
be boxers if they wanted to
now when i talk about them going into a
gym i don't talk about them going into a
gym with a view to become a professional
fighter but it is interesting to hear
sometimes when people work in an
industry if they actually would put
their most precious person i want my i
want my children
to chase their dreams in terms of the
passion that's that's that's lit within
them
right and if that's through boxing then
i would 100 support that now if i had a
choice would i want them to be fighters
absolutely not if i had a choice would i
want them to be part of
our company my company our family
business
not really no not like you took on from
not from because
people think that it's you know a nice
you know what's been given the reigns if
you like but it's a different kind of
struggle you know it's not the struggle
to necessarily put food on the table but
it's a struggle to make your own name in
your own right because when you when
you're born to a successful father and
you see this in sport i mean chris
eubank you know with his dad connor ben
one of our fighters with his dad nigel
ben you're always nigel ben's son or
chris eubank's son so
the struggle is more to create your own
identity you know and to do that you
have to go above and beyond what they
did do you feel you've done it yeah i do
but what was the moment you felt you did
it i think with with what we've done for
boxing you know my dad was a huge
promoter in the uk you know still is a
cool snooker but never went
internationally and did major tv deals
never staged
mega fights in america like i have and
all those kind of stuff and that was
like a subconscious chip on the shoulder
to say that's the only way i can get
respected
because otherwise i've just been given
it and i was given it you know i was
given an opportunity that others
wouldn't have so i had to go above and
beyond that but i don't want
my daughters to have the same kind of
pressures if you like to sort of try and
outperform me but i want them to be
passionate about something
and that's why
i come back to sport because we live in
an age where kids are on their phones
and that you know that they're not out
they're not exercising
they're reading negativity on social
media and it's just a complete
you know influx of of information in
that respect sport is the answer
on
your deals and forging into new markets
getting that chip off your shoulder and
doing different doing different deals
bringing boxing to different places you
are forging into new markets like the
middle east specifically saudi arabia
and you said in 2019 you wanted saudi to
be the home of mega boxing uh take over
from vegas how's that going obviously
there's been a global pandemic yeah well
it was you know we did anti-joshua
against andy ruiz the rematch there
which was went very well um you know it
was a huge event obviously 2020 was
significantly slowed down 2021 sorry
from from the pandemic
there are talks with not just saudi
arabia but of course abu dhabi dubai and
that region about bringing major fights
there and they're going to be very
aggressive in that marketplace because
you know there is a desire from those
countries to bring major sporting events
there you talk though about trying to do
what's right and i wonder do you have
any moral qualms about a country where i
don't know women weren't allowed to
drive until recently human rights
concerns especially with saudi arabia
well i think if they want to change and
if they're going to change they need to
make statements and they need to bring a
focus on their territory i mean you talk
about you know sport washing which is a
question that really you're referring to
and the answer is is if you want to
modernize you know a world or a country
like like saudi arabia they want to do
it in many different ways but bringing
big events to that territory is very
important to them
when i say about you know formula one
going to saudi arabia the pga
golf tour
wwe major tennis tournaments
it's not that i passed the buck and say
look we're only boxing what why
shouldn't we
but
boxing
is prize fighting okay so it's very
different i don't really have a right to
say to anthony joshua and andy ruiz
we've had this offer
you guys are going in to fight each
other and this is the opportunity for
you
i mean andy murray of course
one of our the uk's greatest tennis
exports that turn down one and a half
million pounds to play in saudi because
of human rights concerns it does happen
i suppose there are individuals yeah but
he's a lot more money than that and
maybe if they offered andy murray more
he would have gone and the opportunity
only seems to be right for your fighters
if the money is right no but that was my
comment on andy murray i mean you're not
talking about i know but you're saying
to me they're prizes they're prize
fighters so i'm trying to get into them
but i'll give you an example yeah if a
fighter
was offered five million dollars to take
a fire and there was an opportunity to
fight for 30 million dollars in a sport
which is incredibly dangerous
and you never know when it's your last
opportunity to be involved in a fight
it's a different kind of conversation
rather than a million dollars to play a
tennis match if you google you mm-hmm do
you do that do you give it yourself not
come on you must a little bit not for a
long time but i think i probably have
done yeah for sure yeah yeah you did it
last night eddie hearn and the memes
these memes of you no context hearn yeah
it's a twitter account yeah it has
several hundred thousand
followers uh what's your favorite one
these are these are things you seem to
just do
yeah i mean it's not you is it yeah
and he said to me look i've watched your
interviews would you mind if i do this
no context hearn no context is something
that exists you know with some other
sites as well and i was like
yeah crack on me i mean how big can that
get and it just went
two thousand followers ten thousand
twenty thousand a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand three hundred and he
just takes clips clips of my interviews
and then and then people use those clips
in context to something else so like you
know when liverpool score or win away at
the weekend
yeah so how do you feel about that
though because some people wouldn't like
it they would actually work really well
for me they wouldn't like themselves i
never take myself too seriously anymore
i think that's very important in life
but
i actually it's worked well for me
because it's opened up a different
audience you know i was known by fight
fans
but now you're talking about you know
kids
sort of young adults
you know more women
because it's everywhere and but the
problem is is you get referred to as the
mean guy and i took my kids to a
trampoline park the other day and there
was a girl letting us in so i mean she
must have been i don't know 16 15. and
she went
is it you and i'm thinking well you know
katie taylor's obviously working here a
lot of younger she goes you're the mean
guy and i was like and my kids you know
that all when i picked them up from
school all the kids are going there
they're not saying that because i'm
doing a show on saturday they're doing
that because of no context earned so
you're the funny man on the internet
yeah but you know
have you got a favorite one whatever it
takes um is that one of you just doing
something you don't even almost remember
yeah there's so many i mean there was me
i was selling strawberries
on a a market store in hull because one
of my boxers their family has a fruit
store in hull a young lady walked past
and i said you in the headband you are
different gravy because you and it's
just they play it all the time and if
there's a footballer with a headband i
mean it's just it gets you yeah and um
but there's so many
i've got to ask you because i've thought
about this and i don't know quite my
decision
what would be your music if you were a
fighter and you were walking in what
would be the tune that you would pick
you must have imagined yourself doing
what some of you know there's a song by
white snake called
here i go again or here we go again and
it was actually a song that mickey ward
a great irish fighter an american
fighter used to walk out to and it's
like yes here we go again walking down
the only road i know it's quite it's
quite deep and what would be your style
do you think you'd walk out eddie
hearn's there the man off the inside i
mean just embarrassing probably like i
think i can dance i think i can sing
yeah i think i'm very limited at both
but you know but i think that i would
look the part
you'd have to yes but i think once the
bell went there'd be a major problem
yeah and it would be for me not for the
other person eddie hearn thank you so
much for talking to me and to our
viewers thank you
and thank you so much for being with us
until we meet again stay safe and
goodbye
[Music]